This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. It was November 2004. Jeopardy Champion Ken Jennings kept winning and winning and winning. He now has $1,4,960. His chief seemed unbreakable. A total of 2 million 6,300 dollars. With Christmas approaching on his 75th appearance on the show, the champion seemed likely to win yet again. It was final jeopardy the last challenge of the episode.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。那是2004年11月。《危险边缘》的冠军肯·詹宁斯一路过关斩将，连战连捷。他目前的奖金已经达到了1,049,600美元。他的连胜记录似乎无人能破。总共2,600,300美元。随着圣诞节临近，这是他在节目中的第75次亮相，这位冠军似乎很有可能再次获胜。这是本期节目的最后一关“终极危险边缘”。
If Ken got this one answer right, the streak would continue. Host Alex Trebek presented the question. The category is business and industry and here is the clue, ladies and gentlemen. Most of this firms, 70,000 seasonal white-color employees, work only four months a year. 30 seconds, good luck. Columbia University psychologist Eric Johnson describes what happened next. So Jennings thought and thought must be seasonal and must be something about Christmas.
如果肯答对这最后一个问题，他的连胜纪录将继续保持。主持人亚历克斯·特雷贝克提出了问题。类别是商业与行业，各位女士先生，线索如下。这家公司的7万名季节性白领员工，每年只工作四个月。30秒，祝你好运。哥伦比亚大学心理学家埃里克·约翰逊描述了接下来发生的事情。所以詹宁斯心想，这肯定得是季节性的，而且一定和圣诞节有关。
So he was thinking maybe it's like someone who does delivery like FedEx or maybe it's people who put outside box-and-os, the Salvation Army. The other contestant with a chance to win, Nancy Zurg, went in a different direction. She picked the tax preparation company, H&R Block, which hires a lot of accountancy cheer, come tax season. Nancy, you wrote down your response rather quickly, I thought, I hope it's correct, let's take a look.
所以他在想，也许就像做快递的人，比如联邦快递，或者也许是在外面摆红世妥（Red Kettles）的救世军。另一位有机会获胜的选手南希·泽夫则走向了不同的方向。她选择了税务筹划公司H&R Block，该公司在税收季会雇用大量会计人员。南希，我想你写下答案的速度相当快，希望它是正确的，我们来看看。
Let's take a look. What is H&R Block? You're right, you're a wager. 4,401, taking you up to 14,401. You have a one dollar lead over Ken Jennings right now and his final response was FedEx. His wager was 5,601. He winds up in second place with 87.99 and Nancy Zerf! Congratulations, you are indeed a giant killer! Our new dribbling champion, Fort 2000, 4 and 1! Ken Jennings knew that H&R blog hired lots of white collar workers during tax preparation season.
我们来看看。什么是H&R Block？你答对了，你的下注是4,401，使你的总分达到了14,401。你现在比肯·詹宁斯多出一美元的领先优势，而他的最终回答是联邦快递。他的下注是5,601。他最终以87.99分获得第二名，而南希·泽夫！恭喜你，你确实是一个巨人杀手！我们新的连胜冠军，4,2000、4和1！肯·詹宁斯知道H&R Block在报税季雇用了大量白领工人。
It's just that once his mind gravitated to companies that were especially active around Christmas, he couldn't pull himself out of that mental groove. And he claims later on, there was absolutely no way that came to his mind. It was just blocked by his initial thoughts. This is something psychologist call inhibition that when you think about one thing, you can't think about the other. This week on Hidden Brain, how our minds can be influenced by the way options are presented to us and how we can make choices more wisely.
只是当他的大脑倾向于那些在圣诞节前后特别活跃的公司时，他就无法让自己摆脱那种思维定式。他后来声称，根本没有那种想法进入他的脑海。它只是被他最初的想法给屏蔽了。心理学家将此称为抑制，即当你思考一件事时，你就无法思考另一件事。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨我们的思维如何受到选项呈现方式的影响，以及我们如何能够做出更明智的选择。
As we move through life, we are constantly making choices. When we buy a car, choose a college, or pick a romantic partner, we think about the ramifications of different options. One thing we usually don't consider, how the way in which choices are presented to us, shapes what we decide to do. At Columbia University, Eric Johnson studies how the presentation of choices can influence people and how these insights can be used for both good and evil. Eric Johnson, welcome to Hidden Brain. Very glad to be with you, Shankar. Some years ago, Eric, a graduate student came
在我们的人生旅程中，我们不断地在做选择。当我们买车、挑选大学或选择浪漫伴侣时，我们会考虑不同选项的后果。有一件事我们通常不会考虑：选项呈现给我们的方式，是如何塑造我们的决定的。在哥伦比亚大学，埃里克·约翰逊研究了选项的呈现方式如何影响人们，以及这些见解如何被用于行善或作恶。埃里克·约翰逊，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴能和你在一起，尚卡尔。几年前，埃里克，有一位研究生来到
to you and said she could change the sofas that customers would buy by changing the background on a website selling the sofas. You were skeptical that this was the case, so she ran a lab experiment to convince you. Can you tell me what she did and what happened? What she suggested is that the background, what's called the wallpaper website, might influence people's choice. So she went out and designed several different website backgrounds. One, for example, would be clouds embedded on a blue sky.
你这里说，她可以通过改变销售沙发的网站背景，来改变顾客购买的沙发。你对这种说法持怀疑态度，于是她做了一个实验室实验来说服你。你能告诉我她做了什么以及发生了什么吗？她建议说，背景，也就是所谓的网站墙纸，可能会影响人们的选择。于是她设计了几种不同的网站背景。例如，其中一个是在蓝天中嵌入朵朵白云。
And she showed that when you asked people what they thought of when they saw that, they would say comfort. Another one might be dollar bills embedded on a green page. And she asked people what they thought of, not surprising, they would say cost. She then gave people a task where they had to choose a couch. Uncouch was expensive and comfortable. The other couch was actually cheap and uncomfortable. And what she found is that people actually chose a couch that was more compatible with the background.
并且她证明了，当人们被问及看到这个背景时会想到什么时，他们会回答“舒适”。另一个背景可能是绿色的页面上嵌入了美元钞票。当她问人们对此有何想法时，不出所料，他们会回答“成本”。接着，她给人们安排了一个任务，让他们选择一张沙发。一张沙发既贵又舒服。而另一张沙发其实很便宜而且不舒服。她发现，人们实际上选择了一张与背景更契合的沙发。
That is with the blue clouds, they would choose the comfortable but more expensive couch. With the green money, they chose a chief uncomfortable couch. You know, this reminds me of a similar situation. This one drawn from real life. The research at Karim Hagag looked at students at the US military academy at West Point. They were taking introductory classes in economics, calculus, chemistry, and other subjects. The students were assigned to these classes at various times of the day. Some took the class first thing in the morning, others took the same class later in the day. Kareem Hagag looked at how likely students were to later choose that subject as their college major. Here's what he found.
也就是说，面对蓝色云朵背景时，他们会选择舒适但更贵的那张沙发。面对绿色钞票背景时，他们会选择便宜且不舒服的沙发。你知道，这让我想起了一个类似的情况。这个例子取材于现实生活。卡里姆·哈加格（Karim Hagag）对美国西点军校学员的研究。他们当时正在修读经济学、微积分、化学和其他学科的入门课程。学员被分配到一天中不同时间段的上课班级。有些人一大清早第一节课就上课，其他人则在一天晚些时候上同样的课。卡里姆·哈加格研究了学生后来将该学科选为大学专业的可能性。以下是他的发现。
Students who were randomly assigned to the first period 730 AM section are about 10% less likely to choose the corresponding major, compared to a student who takes that class later in the day. We also compare two students who are sitting in the exact same classroom, but one of whom just had a free period as a break before, and the other came from one or more back-to-back classes. We find that each additional back-to-back class reduces the likelihood that that student enrolls in the major by about 12%.
被随机分配到第一节早上7点30分上课的学生，与晚些时候上该课程的学生相比，选择相应专业的可能性大约低10%。我们还对比了坐在同一间教室里的两名学生，其中一人刚上完一节自由活动课作为休息，而另一人则刚连续上了多节背靠背的课程。我们发现，每多上一节背靠背的课程，该学生选修该专业的可能性就会降低约12%。
It's not quite fluffy clouds and so far, but it's the same general principle, something that should not influence a consequential decision, like which major you select in college seems to be influenced by when the class was scheduled, or if you took that class right after a challenging class. What's interesting about that example is the decision is actually quite a while after you've taken the class. You're not sitting there at 9 a.m. in the Calculus class making a decision. Some day later you're given a form, what do you want as a major? And the memory of how awful you felt during that Calculus class or during that economics class
这虽然不像飘浮的云朵和沙发那么轻松，但这是同一个普遍原则：本不该影响重大决定（比如你在大学里选择哪个专业）的事情，似乎却受到了课程安排的时间，或者你是否在上一门具有挑战性的课程后紧接着上这门课的影响。关于这个例子，有趣的是，这个决定实际上是在你上完课很久之后才做出的。你并不是在早晨9点的微积分课上坐在那里做决定的。几天后，你拿到了一张表格：你想选什么专业？而你对当时上微积分课或经济学课时感觉有多糟糕的记忆，
actually is what's influencing your choice. So it's not only that immediate environment, like the web pages, but it's also the memories of that environment that make a difference. One last idea along the same lines, you've asked volunteers how much they care about global climate change and global warming and what they would be willing to do to fix it. But you've also measured something curious. You've measured what the ambient temperature is as they're answering the question. Describe to me the setup of the study
实际上正是影响你选择的因素。所以不仅是像网页这样的即时环境会产生影响，对该环境的记忆也会产生影响。最后一个相关的观点是：你曾询问志愿者他们有多关心全球气候变化和全球变暖，以及他们愿意做些什么来解决这个问题。但你还测量了一个奇怪的变量。你测量了他们在回答问题时的环境温度。请描述一下这个实验的设置，
and what you found Eric. So, hey, people come to our website. And one of the things we asked them about was what was the zip code. And my co-authors cleverly figured out they could actually figure out what the temperature that day was as they were answering the questionnaire. And so much like the website color might change choice, we're wondering whether the ambient temperature would change how concerned they were with global warming.
以及你发现了什么，埃里克。嗯，人们来到我们的网站。我们询问他们的事情之一就是他们的邮政编码。我的合著者很聪明地发现，他们实际上可以查出填写问卷当天受访者身处环境的温度。因此，就像网站颜色可能会改变选择一样，我们在想环境温度是否会改变他们对全球变暖的关注程度。
And in some studies, actually, how much they would donate for a global warming charity. And surprisingly, we found that on days that were warmer than average, people would give more money and be more concerned about global warming. Days that were colder than average, they were much less concerned about global warming and they gave us money. I understand that experiments have been run along the same lines where you can actually manipulate the temperature, you know, fiddle with the thermostat and you get similar results. Yeah, if the research we've done that actually come up with various more results at warmer temperatures, increase concern with global warming.
在某些研究中，实际上还考察了他们愿意为全球变暖慈善机构捐赠多少钱。出乎意料的是，我们发现，在温度高于平均值的日子里，人们会捐出更多的钱，并且更加关注全球变暖。而在温度低于平均值的日子里，他们对全球变暖的关注要少得多，捐的钱也少。我了解到，人们曾沿着同样的思路进行实验，你可以实际操弄温度，你知道，摆弄恒温器，也能得到类似的结果。是的，我们所做的研究实际上得出了更多结果：较高的温度会增加对全球变暖的关注。
We've actually done something recently called a meta-analysis when we look at all the studies that have looked at this and there's a significant and reasonable effect of ambient temperature no matter how you manipulate it on people's concern for climate change. So what's interesting here are the kids that if you ask the people buying the sofas or you ask the college students deciding on the major or the volunteers in a hot room why they make the decisions they did, how many of them do you think would point to those hidden factors as the reason for that decision? I can tell you in our studies when we ask people, were you influenced by how warm it was today? Nobody says yes.
我们最近做了一项名为元分析的研究，我们审视了所有研究这一课题的研究，结果表明，无论你如何操弄环境温度，它对人们气候变化关注度的影响都是显著且合理的。这里有趣的地方在于，如果你问那些购买沙发的顾客、决定专业的大学生，或者身处炎热房间的志愿者，他们为什么会做出那样的决定，你认为他们中有多少人会把这些隐藏的因素作为他们做出该决定的原因？我可以告诉你，在我们的研究中，当我们问人们“你今天是否受到了气温高低的影响？”时，没有人回答“是”。
It's something that is actually sort of like a fish and water. It's something we don't see. And we're not aware of those external influences. So we've looked at how people can be blind to why they are making a certain choice. But the same blindness often affects people who are offering choices. Some time ago, the states of New Jersey and Pennsylvania moved to introduce cheaper options for car insurance for consumers, but New Jersey inadvertently made it easier for customers
这实际上就像水中的鱼一样。这是我们看不见的东西。而且我们并没有意识到这些外部影响。所以我们已经探讨了人们如何会对导致自己做出特定选择的原因视而不见。但同样的盲目性也常常影响着那些提供选择的人。一段时间前，新泽西州和宾夕法尼亚州开始为消费者推出更便宜的汽车保险选项，但新泽西州无意中让消费者更容易
to select the cheaper plan Pennsylvania made it harder. We'll talk later on about what the state specifically did, but for now can you tell me what differences it actually make to consumers? You might say that current insurance costs a lot of money, people would take the time and trouble to figure out the best deal. You've studied what happened, did customers behave differently in New Jersey relative to Pennsylvania? It's actually interesting because living there and getting the forms themselves, I saw it real time. In New Jersey, the JAPR policy was much more popular about three times as popular as in
选择较便宜的方案，而宾夕法尼亚州则让选择变得更难。我们稍后会讨论这两个州具体做了什么，但现在你能告诉我们，这实际上对消费者造成了什么不同吗JAPR？你可能会说当前的保险花费很多金钱，人们会花时间和精力去找出最好的优惠。你研究过发生的事情，新泽西州的客户的行为与宾夕法尼亚州的客户相比有什么不同吗？这其实很有趣，因为我在那里生活过，也亲自拿到了这些表格，我是实时看到的。在新泽西州，JAPR保单要受欢迎得多，受欢迎程度大约是宾夕法尼亚州的
Pennsylvania where the expensive policy was very popular. There was a very big difference in the kind of insurance people bought in the two states. So you and your colleague Dan Goldstein calculated the ultimate difference between the two states, and you found that customers in Pennsylvania spent $2 billion additional dollars that's billion with a B on current shores. I mean, that's just gigantic. And it's probably more now because we calculated that in 2003, and the differences still exist. I understand that you even wrote to the governors of the two states and published an op-ed
三倍；而在宾夕法尼亚州，昂贵的保单非常受欢迎。这两个州人们购买的保险种类存在很大差异。所以你和你的同事丹·戈德斯坦计算了两个州之间的最终差异，你们发现宾夕法尼亚州的消费者在当前保险上额外多花费了20亿美元——注意，这个“B”代表十亿美元。我的意思是，这简直是个天文数字。现在可能更多了，因为我们是在2003年计算的，而且这种差异至今依然存在。据我所知，你甚至给这两个州的州长写了信，并在宾夕法尼亚州的一家报纸上发表了一篇专栏文章
about your thoughts in a Pennsylvania newspaper, but people blew you off. Again, the idea that the way choices are presented to people could make a difference in how people made decisions, that idea seemed ridiculous to people. We didn't even hear anything from the governors, although actually eventually we did get a letter from Christy Whitman with the governor of New Jersey saying she'll give it to somebody, but it didn't have any immediate impact.
来表达你的想法，但人们对你置之不理。再次说明，向人们呈现选择的方式可能会对人们的决策产生影响这一观点，在当时人们看来似乎荒谬绝伦。我们甚至没有收到州长的任何回音，尽管后来时任新泽西州州长的克里斯蒂·惠特曼确实给我们回过信，说她会把信转交给某人，但这并没有产生任何立竿见影的影响。
So in recent years, there's been increasing interest in how we respond to choices and how best to present choices to others. Research us call this field of study choice architecture. Can you tell me about the origins of that term? The term comes from actually rigid-thaler and cast sunsteen in the book Nudge. And what it means is that somebody is making a set of decisions about how to present the choice to you. They are what I'll call tools for choice architecture, deciding how many options to present to you,
因此，近年来，人们对我们如何对选择做出反应以及如何向他人最好地呈现选择产生了越来越多的兴趣。研究人员将这一研究领域称为“选择架构”。你能跟我讲讲这个术语的起源吗？这个术语实际上源自理查德·塞勒和卡斯·桑斯坦在《助推》一书中的观点。它的意思是，有人正在做出关于如何向你呈现选择的一系列决定。他们就是我所谓的选择架构工具的制定者，决定向你呈现多少个选项，
deciding the order of the options, deciding how to describe the options. But the key to choice architecture is a little realization, and that realization is, well, maybe we can pick the way to present a choice that helps people make the best decision. In some ways, if you think about what an architect does when she's designing an actual building, the architects making choices, how big do you want the entry way to be?
决定选项的顺序，决定如何描述选项。但选择架构的关键在于一个微小的认识，而这个认识就是：也许我们可以选择一种呈现选项的方式，来帮助人们做出最佳决策。从某种意义上说，如果你想想建筑师在设计实际建筑时做的事情，建筑师就在做选择：你希望入口处有多大？
Do you want a big grand entrance? Do you want a humble entrance? Do you want open spaces? Do you want close spaces? And presumably, each of those choices changes the way people will behave inside that building. And I think the inside here is that by modifying the choices or the way choices are presented to people, in some ways you're inviting them into your building to walk in a certain way, to behave in a certain way. It's absolutely true. We have a brand new business school building. And when we talk to the architects, they said,
你想要一个宏伟的大入口吗？你想要一个简朴的入口吗？你想要开放的空间吗v？你想要封闭的空间吗？据推测，每一个这样的选择都会改变人们在该建筑内部的行为方式。我认为这里的真理在于，通过修改选择或向人们呈现选择的方式，在某种程度上，你是在邀请他们走进你的建筑，以某种特定的方式行走，以某种特定的方式行为。事实确实如此。我们有一栋全新的商学院大楼。当我们与建筑师交谈时，他们说，
the stairs are actually right up front and the elevators weigh in the back. So people actually take the stairs rather than the elevator. The other thing that's really important is that notice there has to be a decision about where the stairs are and where the elevator is. There's no architecture option. You have to decide where those go.
楼梯实际上就在正前方，而电梯则在最里面。所以人们实际上会选择走楼梯而不是坐电梯。另一件非常重要的事情是，请注意，必须对楼梯在哪里以及电梯在哪里做出决定。没有不设架构这种选项。你必须决定这些设施去往何处。
And so it's not as if somebody's not a choice architect. You can be a choice architect knowingly, mindfully, or you can be a choice architect without really realizing what you're doing. You cite a very interesting historical example from the from the actual world of architecture to illustrate how choice architecture works. On the night of the 10th of May 1941, our house to Commons once destroyed and we have now to consider whether we should build it up again and how. In 1943, there were plans to reconstruct the British House of Commons, which had been destroyed during the German Blitz in World War II. This led to an interesting
所以，并不是说某人不是选择架构师。你可以是有意识地、留心成为一名选择架构师，也可以是在并未真正意识到自己在做什么的情况下成为选择架构师。你引用了建筑学实际领域中的一个非常有趣的的历史例子来说明选择架构是如何运作的。1941年5月10日之夜，我们的下议院曾被彻底摧毁，我们现在必须考虑是否应该重建它以及如何重建。1943年，人们制定了重建英国下议院的计划，该议院在第二次世界大战的德国闪电战中被摧毁。这引发了一场有趣的
debate about how the building should be reconstructed. Tell me what happened, Eric. Yes, it turns out Winston Churchill really had been at that point in Parliament for three decades and he made a very impassioned speech saying he wanted the building rebuilt the same way. The quote that really attracted me to the story is he said, we shape our buildings and afterwards our buildings shape us. What he pointed out is that basically unlike the way, for example, Egos Congress is organized, it's also been the case that Parliament had two sides facing each other. In fact, historically, there were exactly two sword links apart, which is important because they were actually using that space as early as the 16th century. And his point is that because you paid attention to the other party,
关于应该如何重建这座建筑的辩论。埃里克，请告诉我发生了什么。是的，事实证明温斯顿·在议会中确实已经待了三十年之久，他发表了一场非常激情的演讲，表示他希望按照原样重建这座建筑。真正吸引我注意的引言是他说：“我们塑造建筑，而后建筑塑造我们。”他指出，基本上与例如美利坚合众国国会的组织方式不同，议会历来都是两边面对面而坐。事实上，从历史上看，它们恰好相隔两个剑的距离，这很重要，因为早在16世纪，他们就在使用那个空间了。他的观点是，因为你关注的是对方党派，
you would pay less attention to what was going on in your own party. You presented more of a united front, and that actually made for much livelier debate and that was very important. He felt for the two-party system in Britain. The other thing he did was make sure the building was too small for everyone so it seemed like it was more intense and more exciting. We attach immense importance to the survival of Parliamentary democracy. We wish to see our parliament a strong, easy, flexible instrument of freedom. This is perfect and slow, train by and a sense of intimacy, our indistence. One of the more consequential examples of inadvertent choice architecture happened in
你就会较少关注自己党派内部发生的事情。你会展现出更加团结的阵线，这实际上使得辩论更加热烈，而这非常重要。他认为这对英国的两党制至关重要。他做的另一件事是确保建筑对所有人来说都显得太小，这样它看起来就会更加紧张和激动人心。我们高度重视议会民主制的生存。我们希望看到我们的议会成为强大、简便、灵活的自由工具。这是完美而缓慢的，由……训练并带来一种亲密感，我们的坚持。无意中产生的选择架构最具影响力的例子之一发生在
the year 2000, a Republican presidential candidate George W. Bush's name was listed first on the ballot in Florida ahead of the Democrat Al Gore. Now it wasn't because Bush came before Gore alphabetically, since the 1950s, the law in Florida was that the candidate belonging to the governor's party would be listed first on the ballot. Eric, what do we know about the effect of ballot order on voting, especially in closed elections? As you may recall, George Bush's brother, Jeb Bush, was the governor, and as you might remember, that was a very close election, about 500 votes separated the two. People spent a lot of
2000年，共和党总统候选人乔治·W·布什的名字被列在佛罗伦萨选票的第一位，排在民主党人阿尔·戈尔之前。这并不是因为布什的名字按字母顺序排在戈尔前面，自20世纪50年代以来，佛罗里达州的法律规定，属于州长党派的候选人将被列在选票的第一位。埃里克，关于选票顺序对投票的影响，我们了解多少，尤其是在势均力敌的选举中？你可能还记得，乔治·布什的弟弟杰布·布什当时是州长，而且你可能也记得，那是一场非常势均力敌的选举，两人之间仅相差大约500票。人们花了大量
time looking at ballots, trying to recount them. There was a famous debate about hanging chads. Now, it turns out that some states actually randomize the order. That is, you go from county to county or precinct to precinct, and the order just differs. So, in half, then, Gore would be first, in the ref, but should be first. That allows us to estimate how big the effect is, and that effect is much larger than 500 votes. It probably is tens of thousands of votes. In fact, John Crosnick, who's a psychologist at Stanford, has argued that if it had been randomized in Florida,
时间查看选票并试图重新计票。当时关于悬垂选票（hanging chads）有一场著名的争论。现在，事实证明，有些州实际上会对顺序进行随机化处理。也就是说，当你从一个县到另一个县，或从一个选区到另一个选区时，顺序是不同的。因此，在有一半的选区中，戈尔会排在第一位，而在其余的选区中，布什会排在第一位。这使我们能够估计这种影响有多大，而这种影响远不止500票。它可能影响了数万张选票。事实上，斯坦福大学的心理学家约翰·克罗斯尼克（John Crosnick）曾辩称，如果在佛罗里达州进行了随机化处理，
Al Gore would have been president. In nearly every domain of our lives, smart marketers and county politicians are already using ideas from choice architecture to change what you buy, to manipulate you at the ballot box, and to influence how you think. When we come back, the psychological mechanisms behind choice architecture and how we can use these insights to help people lead better lives. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
阿尔·戈尔就会成为总统。在我们生活几乎每一个领域，聪明的营销人员和精明的政治家都已经在使用选择架构的理念来改变你的购买行为，在投票箱前操纵你，并影响你的思维方式。稍事休息后，我们将探讨选择架构背后的心理机制，以及我们如何利用这些见解来帮助人们过上更好的生活。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In his book, The Elements of Choice, the psychologist Eric Johnson explores the world of choice architecture. He studies why we fail to see that our decisions can be subtly biased by the way choices are presented to us. He also examines how we routinely present choices to others in ways that turn out to be counterproductive. Some years ago, Eric, a researcher presented visitors who wanted to sign up for a new social media platform with an online agreement. It was very long and buried deep inside the
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。心理学家埃里克·约翰逊在他的新书《选择的要素》中，探索了选择架构的世界。他研究了为什么我们意识不到自己的决策会受到选择呈现方式的潜移默化之影响。他还探讨了我们如何经常以适得其反的方式向他人呈现选择。几年前，埃里克，一位研究人员向想要注册新社交媒体平台的访客提供了一份在线协议。协议非常长，其中深深隐藏着
the clause to me. What we did is we went to the extreme and we included this first born clause suggesting that if you agreed to these policies that as a form of payment you'd be giving up a first born child and 98% of the participants that took the study didn't even notice this particular clause. So nearly every single person agreed to hand over their first born child in exchange for access to the new social media platform. Now obviously the researchers were not looking to steal people's kids, but it's an astonishing example of how people can be led to make bad decisions.
那个条款。我们做的是采取了极端做法，我们在其中加入了这个“长子条款”，暗示如果你同意这些政策，作为支付形式，你将放弃你的第一个孩子，而98%参与这项研究的参与者甚至没有注意到这个特定的条款。因此，几乎每一个人都同意交出他们的长子，以此换取访问新社交媒体平台的权限。现在很明显，研究人员并不是为了偷走人们的孩子，但这是一个令人震惊的例子，说明人们是如何被诱导做出糟糕决策的。
Erika want to look at the different mechanisms that play in choice architecture, and I want to start with the idea that when the right choice involves waiting through a lot of difficult material, people often make the wrong choice. I think that's true. In fact, a really important observation is that people make decisions early on when they're making a choice about how to make that choice. They actually are doing what I think is choosing a plausible path how to make the decision. When we do that, we often are very, very sensitive
埃里克，我想探讨选择架构中起作用的不同机制，我想从这样一个观点开始：当正确的选择需要阅读大量困难的材料时，人们往往会做出错误的选择。我认为确实如此。事实上，一个非常重要的观察结果是，人们在刚开始就如何做出选择做出决定时，他们实际上在做我认为是“选择如何做出决策的合理路径”的事情。当我们这样做时，我们往往非常非常敏感
to how much effort is involved, particularly at the beginning. So you go, you want to join this brand new media service, you're excited, and it says, first, read all this, and that can be 10,000 words, and then click here. It's not a surprise that most people don't do that long bit of reading and just click there. Something very similar happened with a rollout of the Affordable Care Act in 2013.
于其中涉及多少努力，尤其是在刚开始的时候。所以你去注册这个崭新的媒体服务，你很兴奋，上面写着：首先，阅读所有这些内容——这可能有1,0000字——然后点击这里。大多数人不会去读那一长串内容，而是直接点击那里，这并不奇怪。在2013年平价医疗法案（Affordable Care Act）推出时，也发生了非常类似的事情。
Here the stakes were really significant and they were real. Can you describe to me what happened when the website went public, Eric? One of the things that was interesting is there were a lot of decisions that a Troyser tech would have to make in designing the site. So for example, there were sites that had only eight options. Other states had sites that had 160 options.
在这里，利害关系确实非常重大，而且是真实的。埃里克，你能向我描述一下当网站公开时发生了什么吗？有趣的事情之一是，选择架构师在设计网站时必须做出许多决策。例如，有些网站只有8个选项。而其他州的网站则有160个选项。
The thing that's interesting is that it's a hard, hard, hard decision because you have three things you need to think about if you're interested in cost. The deductible, which is how much you pay every time you use the doctor. There is a copayment, and then there's a premium. People can't do the math of adding those three up. So we did a set of studies where we actually had people say, find the cheapest insurance, and almost everybody couldn't. They just can't do the math, and as a result, they were making choices that actually cost on average
有趣的是，这是一个非常非常困难的决定，因为如果你对成本感兴趣，你需要考虑三件事。免赔额（Deductible），即你每次去看医生时支付的金额。还有共付额（Copayment），然后是保费（Premium）。人们无法算出将这三者加起来的总和。因此，我们做了一系列研究，让人们去寻找最便宜的保险，结果几乎所有人都找不到。他们就是算不出这笔账，因此，他们做出的选择实际上让他们的平均花费
hundreds of dollars more than they should. And of course, when you multiply this out over millions of people across an entire nation, the cost actually become quite astronomical. Your estimate was $9 billion of excess premiums being paid. So you talked a second ago about how people have a strong impulse to follow the path of least resistance. Another place where this affects us is when we go shopping. Can you paint me a picture of the lengths that companies go to to seek the right placement for their products in bookstores
比本应支付的多出几百美元。当然，当把这个数字乘以全国数百万人口时，成本实际上变得相当惊人。你的估计是多支付了90亿美元的超额保费。所以你刚才谈到人们有一种强烈的冲动去遵循阻力最小的路径。另一个受此影响的地方是当我们去购物时。你能给我描绘一下公司为了在书店
and on grocery shelves? Not everybody knows this. There is actually payments that companies will give to supermarkets to put products in favorite positions. For example, it turns out just below eye level, you're much more likely to sell than if you're saying, for example, at knee level. And the mechanism seems to be people are very sensitive to the little bit of effort it might take to kneel down.
和杂货店货架上为产品争取最佳摆放位置而付出的种种努力吗？并非所有人都知道这一点。公司实际上会向超市支付费用，以便将产品放在受青睐的位置。例如，事实证明，在视线稍下方的位置，产品的销量要远远大于例如膝盖高度的位置。而其中的机制似乎是人们对下跪可能需要的一点点努力非常敏感。
Imagine you have a child in your cart and you're rolling around, you wanna get done. The last thing you wanna do is read labels at levels that are very low, you grab and go. And this is true across all forms of commerce. So companies like Google, for example, pay other companies like Apple to come pre-installed on you know iPhones and iPads. Now anyone can navigate over to Google, but having it pre-installed
想象一下，你的购物车里坐着一个孩子，你正在四处走动，你想赶紧买完。你最不想做的事情就是在非常低的高度阅读标签，你会直接抓起东西就走。这在所有形式的商业中都是如此。因此，像谷歌这样的公司会向苹果等公司支付费用，让谷歌成为iPhone和iPad上的预装软件。现在任何人都可以导航到谷歌，但让它成为预装软件
makes the choice a tiny bit easier, and this turns out to make a big difference. It turns out that in fact very very few people actually make the shift from Google Let's say to Microsoft Bing or any other website. And in fact, they stick with that. So that stickiness is because we don't want to spend the time to actually the three or four clicks or touches that would take us to change what this default search option is. I'm reminded of a study by Roluka Ursue at New York University, she looked at how people picked hotel accommodations on Expedia. You've cited this in your book.
会让选择变得稍微容易一点，而事实证明这会产生巨大的影响。事实证明，实际上极少数人会真正从谷歌转向微软必应或其他任何网站。事实上，他们会一直坚持使用它。这种黏性存在的原因是我们不想花时间和精力去进行那三四次点击或触摸来改变这个默认的搜索选项。这让我想起了纽约大学的罗卢卡·乌尔苏（Roluca Ursu）的一项研究，她研究了人们如何在Expedia上选择酒店住宿。你在书中引用过这个例子。
Do you remember what you found? It was actually quite striking because it's one of the cases where we know the data that would have normally been known only to the company. I should point out that Expedia makes most of its money from hotel rooms. We think about this flights and rental cars, but a big part of its money from hotel rooms. We think of them as flights and rental cars, but a big part of their revenue is hotel rooms. And so they typically present, say, 30 hotel rooms to somebody. And there you can do it in lots of orders.
你还记得你发现了什么吗？这实际上相当引人注目，因为这是我们了解通常只有公司自己才知道的数据的案例之一。我应该指出，Expedia的大部分收入来自酒店房间。我们认为它们是航班和租车，但它们很大一部分收入来自酒店房间。我们认为它们是航班和租车，但它们很大一部分收入来自酒店房间。所以他们通常会向某人展示大约30间酒店房间。你可以按许多不同的顺序来展示它们。
So the question that Reluca was looking at is how important it is to be in first, second, third, et cetera. And what she found was basically the first one actually got a share that was 50% more than if it was second. Wow. You know, we talked earlier about the current insurance options offered by New Jersey and Pennsylvania. I want to go back to that example in a little more detail to see why so many customers picked the cheaper insurance in New Jersey, but failed to do so in Pennsylvania.
因此，罗卢卡所研究的问题是，排在第一位、第二位、第三位等究竟有多么重要。她发现，排在第一位的酒店所获得的份额实际上比排在第二位时高出50%之多。哇。你知道，我们之前讨论过新泽西州和宾夕法尼亚州提供的当前保险选项。我想更详细地回到那个例子，看看为什么那么多消费者在新泽西州选择了较便宜的保险，但在宾夕法尼亚州却没有这样做。
Can you explain to me what they saw? What was different about that choices that prompted them to make the right decision in one state and the wrong decision in another? Well, I think one of the big things is ease. I mean, it turns out that the forms, I saw them because I was there, were in tiny print on onion skin paper.
你能向我解释一下他们看到了什么吗？这些选择有什么不同，促使他们在某一个州做出正确的决定而在另一个州做出错误的决定？嗯，我认为其中一个最大的因素是简便性。我的意思是，事实证明，那些表格——因为我在现场所以我看到了——是用极小的字体印在洋葱皮纸上的。
And I would have to, in theory, read that to understand what's going on. Check a box and send it back in again. The effort, well, particularly the prediction of effort was large. The question is, what happened if you didn't make a choice? In New Jersey, if I didn't make a choice, I got a policy that was cheaper and didn't have quite as much coverage. In Pennsylvania, I got the more expensive coverage that was more complete. So we call that a default. It happens if you have no action. And those defaults made all the difference in
理论上我必须阅读这些内容才能理解发生了什么。勾选一个方框然后寄回去。这种努力，嗯，特别是对所需努力的预测是很大的。问题是，如果你不做选择会发生什么？在新泽西州，如果我不做选择，我会得到一份更便宜且保障范围稍少一点的保单。在宾夕法尼亚州，我会得到更贵、更全面的保障。所以我们称之为“默认项”。当你不采取任何行动时，它就会发生。而这些默认项对
the world and those choices. When you talk about this idea of the default, it basically suggests that what happens to the person in the absence of their making a choice turns out to be really consequential. That's right. And it's easy to think about three reasons why that might be the case. One is, as we've been talking about, it's easier to take the default. I don't have to fill out a form. I don't have to find a stamp to send in the form. It's easier, but that's not all that's going on. It turns out defaults work best when that is accompanied by people thinking that the person posing the choice, the designer thinks that's the best option. So maybe I think New Jersey thinks
那些选择产生了截然不同的重大影响。当你谈到默认项这个概念时，它基本上表明，在个人没有做出选择的情况下发生在他们身上的事情，结果证明具有真正重大的影响。的确如此。而且很容易想到为什么会出现这种情况的三个原因。第一，正如我们一直在讨论的那样，接受默认项更容易。我不必填写表格。我不必去找邮票把表格寄出去。这样更容易，但这并非全部原因。事实证明，当默认项伴随着人们认为提出选择的人、设计者认为这是最佳选项的想法时，默认项的效果最好。所以也许我认为新泽西州认为
this is the best option. That is what we call endorsement. And finally, there's a third source and whether things that really makes defaults work is what we call endowment, which is basically thinking that I have this insurance policy, I can think of what's good about it. Therefore, I'm more likely to choose it. One of the more unusual ways in which choice architecture works is by taking advantage of how memory works. There's an entertainer named Darren Brown, who's known in the UK as a mentalist. He doesn't necessarily claim to have psychic
这是最好的选项。这就是我们所说的“背书”。最后，还有第三个来源，即真正让默认项发挥作用的因素是我们所说的“禀赋效应”，也就是基本上认为我拥有这份保险单，我能想到它的好处。因此，我更有可能选择它。选择架构运作的更寻常的方式之一是利用记忆运作的方式。有一位名叫达伦·布朗（Derren Brown）的艺人，在英国被称为“心灵魔术师”。他并不一定声称自己拥有通灵
powers, but he does have an uncanny ability to seemingly read people's minds. In one trick, he brings two advertising executives into an office and gives them instructions on coming up with a slogan for a taxidermy shop Can you describe the setup of what he does and what happens next Eric? Yeah, these two executives Tony and Martin actually are taking to the office in a cab They're then brought up to the office and Darren asked them to create an ad campaign for an unusual business It's actually an animal taxidermy business. Now the idea is you've only got half an hour to do this. So you've got to really work with your
能力，但他确实拥有一种不可思议的能力，似乎能看穿人们的心思。在一个戏法中，他把两位广告高管带进一间办公室，并指导他们为一个动物标本剥制店想一个标语。埃里克，你能描述一下他所做事情的设定以及接下来发生了什么吗？是的，这两位高管托尼和马丁实际上是坐着出租车被带到办公室的。然后他们被带上楼，达伦要求他们为一个不寻常的业务创作一个广告活动。这实际上是一个动物标本剥制业务。这个想法是，你只有半小时的时间来完成这件事。所以你必须真正依靠你的
first instinct. So at the moment you've got no idea what you're going to do, correct? Yeah. He shows them a piece of taxidermy and a cat that's been stuffed and then he puts a piece of paper that has his ideas in an envelope and then puts underneath one of the stuffed cats and leaves a room, comes back in a half hour and they have drawn on the whiteboard what they think a good ad would be including a logo and a slogan. And they have a nice thing which is a bear playing a harp in front of the pearly gates. And they've named the business animal heaven and had the slogan, the best place for dead animals.
第一直觉。所以在这一刻，你根本不知道你要做什么，对吧？是的。他给他们看了一个标本剥制件、一只被做成标本的猫，然后他把一张写有他想法的纸放进信封里，然后把它放在其中一只标本猫下面并离开房间，半小时后回来，他们在白板上画出了他们认为好的广告，包括一个标志和一个标语。他们有一个很好的构想，那就是一只熊在珍珠门前弹竖琴。他们把业务命名为“动物天堂”，标语是“死去的动物最好的归宿”。
Now, round being a very theatrical musician says, very interesting. I do want to show you my own ideas from beforehand. Okay. The mentalist pulls out the envelope that has been sitting in the room the whole time. The logo was almost identical. It's a hot playing bear. The gas when he pulls it out.
现在，扮演一个戏剧性音乐家的布朗说：“非常有趣。我确实想向你们展示我事先的想法。好的。”这位心灵魔术师拿出了自始至终一直放在房间里的信封。标志几乎一模一样。是一只弹竖琴的熊。当他把它拿出来时，他们倒吸了一口气。
It's called creature heaven. There's a harb, a bear, and clouds and gates. And the logo actually looks just like his. The slogan differed only in two words. So they are actually quite impressed. Well, this is scary really. Gobbsmacked I think is a better term one of them uses. And you have to ask how do you do this? Remember, there was a cab ride and Brown and his staff had basically rigged that cab ride.
它叫“生物天堂”。有一个竖琴、一头熊、云朵和门。而且这个标志看起来确实和他的差不多。标语只有两个词不同。所以他们其实相当印象深刻。嗯，这真的很吓人。其中一个人用的更好的词是“惊呆了”。你不得不问你是怎么做到这一点的？记住，当时有一次出租车之旅，布朗和他的团队基本上对那次出租车之旅进行了安排。
For example, the cab came to the London Zoo. There's a huge set of iron gates and they stopped there. And as they were stopping for a bunch of kids crossing the road, the kids were all dressed in t-shirts that had a picture of the zoo. Finally, on the way in, they passed lots of images of harps, happened being storefronts. So what Brown was doing is actually making these ideas more accessible to AdExx. In fact, I argue he wasn't really a mind reader. He was much more a mind writer imposing these ideas in their heads. It's comforting to know that you're just as susceptible to subliminal persuasions as the rest of us. Thank you very much. Helping yourself. Thank you. Martin. Pleasure. Take us, thank you very much. I'll be in sound. So, thank you. Martin. Pleasure.
例如，出租车来到了伦敦动物园。那里有一大组铁门，他们在那里停了下来。当他们停下来等待一群过马路的孩子时，孩子们都穿着印有动物园图片的T恤。最后，在进去的路上，他们经过了许多竖琴的图像，恰好是店面。所以布朗正在做的是让这些想法更容易被广告人获取。事实上，我辩称他并不是真正的读心术士。他更像是一个写心术士，把这些想法强加在他们的脑海中。很高兴知道你和我们其他人一样容易受到潜意识说服的影响。非常感谢。自便。谢谢。马丁。荣幸。带上我们，非常感谢。我会……所以，谢谢。马丁。荣幸。
Take care. Thank you very much, and do well. Bye-bye. I'll be spelling you. Because you're mine. One curious aspect of choice architecture has to do with the order in which choices are presented to us. The National Bureau of Economic Research has an email newsletter where they round up interesting studies in the field of economics.
保重。非常感谢，祝一切顺利。再见。我会……因为你是我的。选择架构的一个奇妙之处与向我们呈现选择的顺序有关。美国国家经济研究局（National Bureau of Economic Research）有一份电子邮件通讯，其中汇总了经济学领域的有趣研究。
And these studies are listed in no particular order, and yet researchers found that some studies get clicked on and downloaded far more often than others. What was going on, Eric? I think it's actually quite an interesting example because the economists think that they are rational, and yet they found that the first option was actually much more likely to be downloaded. Researchers looked at actually if those papers were cited by other papers later on and found that order effect still lasted. So citations actually, what academics love, that's what gets them reputations. That's what can get them tenure. And it turns out even citations were affected by this random ordering of which paper was first. If being forced on a list can inadvertently communicate that
这些研究没有按任何特定顺序列出，然而研究人员发现，某些研究被点击和下载的次数远多于其他研究。埃里克，这究竟是怎么回事？我认为这实际上是一个非常有趣的例子，因为经济学家认为自己是理性的，然而他们却发现第一个选项实际上更有可能被下载。研究人员实际上观察了这些论文是否在后来被其他论文引用，并发现这种顺序效应依然存在。因此引用率实际上——学术界所热爱的东西，那是他们声誉的来源。那是他们获得终身教职的途径。事实证明，甚至连引用率都受到这篇论文是否排在第一位的随机排序的影响。如果被迫排在清单上可以无意中传达出
you're special, sometimes being last confers an advantage to. In competitions where judges are evaluating a series of performances, the final performers have a big advantage. Researchers call these twin patterns the primacy effect and the recency effect. When you have control over the list, you're going to get primacy being first is best. But when the choice architect has control over the list, you may well get recency. Think about the following example. You're in a restaurant.
你很特殊，有时排在最后也能带来优势。在评委评估一系列表演的比赛中，最后的表演者具有很大的优势。研究人员将这两种平行的模式称为“首因效应”和“近因效应”。当你对清单拥有控制权时，你会获得首因效应，即排在第一位是最好的。但当选择架构师对清单拥有控制权时，你很可能会获得近因效应。考虑以下例子。你在一家餐厅。
It's probably the case if you get a paper menu. The first option will have an advantage. But imagine a fancy restaurant where they give you a verbal menu. They read things. You are likely to forget what the first option is and only remember the last one and that turns out to be an advantage. When we come back, how to apply these insights to improve our lives and the ethical questions that arise when you use psychology to manipulate people. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Many of us go through life making choices,
如果你拿到纸质菜单，情况可能就是这样。第一个选项将具有优势。但想象一下一家高级餐厅，他们提供口头菜单。他们念出菜单上的菜品。你很可能会忘记第一个选项而只记得最后一个，事实证明这是一种优势。稍后我们将探讨如何将这些见解应用到改善我们的生活中，以及当你利用心理学来操纵人们时出现的道德问题。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们许多人在生活中做出选择，
or offering choices to others, without realizing that the manner in which choices are presented regularly shapes how people think. Columbia University psychologist Eric Johnson is an expert on the subject of what is called choice architecture. Eric, I want to look at some ways your insights might change the way we parent our kids, manage our employees, and serve our communities. One idea we explored was the power of the path of least resistance, when our streaming television channel automatically plays the next episode of the series we are watching, we are much more likely to binge episodes than if we had to do something as small as pick up the remote and hit play.
或者为他人提供选择，却没有意识到选择呈现的方式经常塑造着人们的思维方式。哥伦比亚大学心理学家埃里克·约翰逊是被称为选择架构这一主题的专家。埃里克，我想探讨一下你的见解如何改变我们养育孩子、管理员工以及服务社区的方式。我们探讨的一个想法是阻力最小路径的力量，当我们的流媒体电视频道自动播放我们正在看的剧集的下一集时，我们比必须做点像拿起遥控器点击播放这样的小事更有可能狂刷剧集。
But some of this laziness can also be deployed for good. Doctors often prescribe brand name drugs, even though cheaper generics are available. This turns out to be costly for consumers, costly for the system, and makes it more likely patients will not take the medications they need. You cite an interesting story about how researchers at Cornell University were able to get doctors to prescribe generic drugs instead of brand name drugs by employing an insight from choice architecture. Can you tell me what they did, Eric? Sure, a former student of mine, it's actually quite gratifying to see this work applied. She actually had the insight that many of the things that had been tried failed because they were
但这种懒惰也可以用于好事。医生经常开名牌药，尽管有更便宜的仿制药可供选择。事实证明，这对消费者来说成本高昂，对医疗系统来说成本高昂，并且使得患者更有可能不服用他们需要的药物。你引用了一个有趣的故事，讲述了康奈尔大学的研究人员如何通过运用选择架构的见解，让医生开仿制药而不是名牌药。埃里克，你能告诉我他们做了什么吗？当然，我以前的一个学生，看到这项工作被应用其实挺令人欣慰的。她实际上有这样一种见解，即许多尝试过的事情都失败了，因为它们是
the wrong diagnosis. It turns out that doctors, when they have a choice, have a name of a brand name drug, let's say his antihistamine, it's called Allegra. It turns out there's a generic drug called Fexafenedine Hydrochloride and that drug is actually cost 20 cents if an Allegra costs a dollar. But of course, that's very hard to remember, very hard to type and all she actually did was a very simple thing. When I started typing alegra, ALL, it put in effects of fennidine hydrochloride. And I could change it if I were a doctor. I just, there's a little button. I clicked it says to prescribe the brand name drug. But almost nobody did. It turns out the increase was from 40% to
错误的诊断。事实证明，医生在有选择时，有一个名牌药的名字，比方说他的抗组胺药，叫做阿莱格拉。事实证明，有一种叫做盐酸非索非那定仿制药，如果阿莱格拉售价一美元，这种药实际上只花20美分。但当然，这很难记住，很难打字，而她实际所做的只是一件非常简单的事情。当我开始输入alegra，即ALL时，它就自动填入了盐酸非索非那定。如果我是医生，我可以更改它。我只是，有一个小按钮。我点击它，上面写着开名牌药。但几乎没有人这样做。事实证明，提供仿制药的比例从40%上升到了
over 90% in supplying the generic drugs. Simply by changing the interface, they had tried previously to pay doctors to do generic drugs. They actually had tried to, or I'll be them by putting up alerts, and all that did was get people annoyed. So this small change in the interface actually changed behavior radically. So doctors like the rest of us follow the path of least resistance and a related idea
超过90%。仅仅通过改变界面，他们之前曾试图付费让医生开仿制药。他们实际上曾尝试过，或者通过弹出提醒来提醒他们，而这一切只会让人烦恼。所以界面上的这个微小改变实际上从根本上改变了行为。因此医生和我们其他人一样遵循阻力最小的路径，以及一个相关想法
that we explored when we talked about how people don't read complex legal documents when they sign up for online services is a value of keeping things simple. You sign in the book the famous story of Captain Chessley-Sullenberger, seconds after he piloted a US Airways plane after it took off from La Guardia airport. A flock of geese hit the plane and both engines went down and Captain Sully, as he's known, had to decide how and where to land the plane in just over three minutes. How did principles from choice architecture help Captain Sully safely land the plane in the Hudson River, Eric? That particular plane is interesting because it had what's called a glass cockpit.
我们在讨论人们在注册在线服务时为什么不阅读复杂的法律文件时探讨过这个想法，那就是保持事情简单的价值。你在书中记述了切斯利·“苏利”·萨伦伯格机长的著名故事，就在他驾驶一架全美航空公司的飞机从拉瓜迪亚机场起飞后几秒钟。一群大雁撞上了飞机，双引擎熄火，被称为苏利机长的他不得不在短短三分钟内决定如何以及在哪里降落飞机。埃里克，选择架构的原则是如何帮助苏利机长将飞机安全降落在哈德逊河上的？那架特定的飞机很有趣，因为它有所谓的玻璃座舱。
It actually runs on electronics and if they lose power, they actually lose a set of gauges in front of them. So what Sully did was very early on within seconds of the collision is reach up and turn on or an auxiliary generator that kept the gauges running. This was important. There was one particular gauge that was very useful to him. It's called the green dot gauge or the air speed tape. And what that does is essentially say,
它实际上靠电子设备运行，如果它们失去动力，他们实际上会失去面前的一组仪表。所以苏利做的是在撞击后几秒钟内非常早地伸出手去打开一个辅助发电机，让仪表保持运转。这很重要。有一个特定的仪表对他非常有用。它被称为绿点仪表或空速带。它的作用本质上是说，
what is the angle which you have to fly to fly as far as possible? Now, he was an expert pilot. He had done this for many, many years. What that let him do is basically decide what angle to fly at, to fly as far as possible. He was actually going to try and land in the Hudson River near 42nd Street where it turns out they're ferry terminals. It was a very cold day. The air temperature was 19 degrees, the water temperature was 42 degrees, and he was very afraid that people would die of hypothermia. Soon after that, the plane splashed into the water
你必须以什么角度飞行才能飞得最远？现在，他是一位经验丰富的飞行员。他这样做已经很多很多年了。这让他的做的基本上是决定以什么角度飞行，以便飞得最远。他实际上打算尝试降落在42街附近的哈德逊河上，那里有渡轮码头。那是一个非常冷的日子。气温是19华氏度，水温是42华氏度，他非常担心人们会死于低体温症。在那之后不久，飞机坠入水中
off Manhattan's west side. Captain Sally picked a spot on the river near the ferry terminal based on the idea that rescuers would be able to reach the plane quickly. Within minutes, several ferry boats arrived as well as rescue crews. Eventually, passengers made their way onto the wing and then to boats, moments later, land.
曼哈顿西岸附近。苏利机长根据救援人员能够迅速到达飞机的想法，在渡轮码头附近的河上选定了一个点。几分钟内，几艘渡轮以及救援人员到达了。片刻之后，乘客们设法上了机翼，然后上了船，随后上岸。
So the striking thing is that the gauges in Fender Captain Sally simplified his decisions. In some ways, you could argue that you could have provided him with more information. There could have been more gauges breaking down all these different things that told him in more granular detail what was going on, but by providing him with this single gauge that allowed him to find the simplified solution to the problem of how far he could fly, it freed up his mind to think about many other considerations, how cold it was, where to land, what happens if he hits someone in the water, whether the plane would float, all these other considerations that he had just three minutes to consider.
所以引人注目的是，苏利机长的仪表简化了他的决定。在某种程度上，你可以辩称本可以为他提供更多信息。可能会有更多仪表细分所有这些不同的事情，以更详细的细节告诉他发生了什么，但通过为他提供这个单一的仪表，使他能够找到关于他能飞多远这个问题的简化解决方案，它解放了他的大脑去思考许多其他考虑因素，有多冷，在哪里降落，如果他撞到水里的人会发生什么，飞机是否会浮起来，所有这些他只有三分钟时间考虑的其他考虑因素。
He talked about the idea of load shedding, and you talk about this idea in the book as well. What is that idea as it applies to choice architecture? As I was reading the transcripts and interviews with him, he had this wonderful line, which is I immediately decided to load shed in goal sacrifice. And load shedding was basically something he stole and pilots use from the electric power industry. If there's too much demand for power, they load shed. And so they made decide they're gonna shut down the factories and leave the power on the hospitals.
他谈到了负荷卸载的想法，你在书中也谈到了这个想法。当这个想法应用于选择架构时，它是什么？当我阅读对他的采访记录时，他有一句精彩的话，那就是我立刻决定进行负荷卸载和目标牺牲。负荷卸载基本上是他从电力行业借用并由飞行员使用的方法。如果电力需求过大，他们就会卸载负荷。所以他们可能会决定关闭工厂，而保持医院的供电。
So what he was doing in the century is saying, what is the decision I can make at hand? And he quickly decided he was gonna be quite comfortable losing the airplane in order to save lives. So to make that trade off, the gauge actually enabled him to think about the things that were important and not about the things that were less important. And he was able to save all the lives of the entire crew and passengers.
所以他本质上在做的是说，我手头可以做出什么决定？他很快决定，为了拯救生命，他可以欣然放弃飞机。因此，为了做出这种权衡，仪表实际上使他能够思考重要的事情，而不是不那么重要的事情。他能够拯救整个机组人员和乘客的生命。
One of the insights that I took away from the research on choice architecture, but also the specific story of what happened with Captain Sully, is the importance of trying to keep things as simple as possible. That in some ways, when things are simple, it frees up your mind to consider all the variables that might suddenly pop up unexpectedly. One of the things that I was really taken by is the fact that the cockpit design is not an accident. They actually use flight simulator so that you actually are training somebody to be a better decision maker.
我从对选择架构的研究中汲取的见解之一，还有关于苏利机长发生的具体故事，就是尽量把事情保持得尽可能简单的。在某种程度上，当事情很简单时，它会解放你的大脑去考虑所有可能突然意外出现的变量。真正吸引我的一点是，座舱设计并非偶然。他们实际上使用飞行模拟器，这样你实际上是在训练某人成为更好的决策者。
The line I like a lot is one of the manufacturers said, we put the information there for their pilot exactly when they need it and only if they need it. Anything else is clutter. Let's look at another application of choice architecture. In this case, the power of defaults. The state of Oregon has used defaults to increase the likelihood that people get registered to vote. How do they do this, Eric?
我很喜欢的一句话是，其中一位制造商说，我们在飞行员恰好需要时、并且仅在他们需要时才将信息准确地放在那里。其他任何东西都是杂乱的干扰。让我们来看看选择架构的另一个应用。在这种情况下，默认值的力量。俄勒冈州利用默认值来增加人们登记投票的可能性。埃里克，他们是如何做到这一点的？
If you go to Oregon, the Department of Motor Vehicles, and you register to get a driver's license, you're automatically a voter. You don't have to fill out another form. It's sometimes called the Motor Voter Registration Law and it turns out about 20 states have actually adopted a version of this registration by default. And it brings up a really important point, which is what should be the default? Every decision has to default. Do you want to fall people into not being voters?
如果你去俄勒冈州的机动车辆管理局登记领取驾照，你自动就是选民。你不需要填写另一份表格。这有时被称为“机动车选民登记法”，事实证明，大约有20个州实际上已经采用了这种默认登记的版本。这就提出了一个非常重要的问题，即默认值应该是什么？每个决定都必须有默认值。你想让人们不知不觉地不成为选民吗？
Or want them to fall into voters? If someone is a citizen, why should they not be a registered voter? By simplifying decision making, we can speed up decisions and get to the best outcome. But there are sometimes when slowing things down can lead to a better result. Choice architecture can help you do this too. Think about the world of dating. Specifically, two dating apps, Tinder and coffee meets Beagle. The big difference between those sites among other things is that on Tinder you have almost an infinite number of potential mates. You can keep swiping as long as your energy left in your thumb. There's actually a phrase called Tinder thumb.
还是想让他们不知不觉地成为选民？如果某人是公民，为什么他们不应该成为登记选民？通过简化决策，我们可以加快决策速度并获得最佳结果。但有时放慢速度可以带来更好的结果。选择架构也可以帮你做到这一点。想想约会的世界。具体来说，两个约会软件，Tinder和Coffee Meets Bagel。这些网站之间的巨大区别除其他外在于，在Tinder上你有几乎无限数量的潜在伴侣。只要你的大拇指还有力气，你就可以一直滑动。其实有个词叫Tinder大拇指。
From the pain you get from doing too much swiping. At Kaufmeat Bangle was actually a site that was built by three women. They wanted to do it as a website that actually was better for women. And they made the decision early on to actually give you a limited number of options, and originally it was just one option a day. So think about what you're doing on Tinder. You're not looking carefully to each potential day.
来自过度滑动带来的疼痛。Coffee Meets Bagel实际上是由三位女性建立的网站。她们希望把它作为一个对女性更友好的网站。她们很早就做出决定，给你提供数量有限的选项，最初一天只有一个选项。所以想想你在Tinder上在做什么。你并没有仔细看每一个潜在的约会对象。
You're probably looking at one easy to read attribute, easy not even to read, easy to look at, which is the picture. If you're only being matched once a day by contrast, you can slow down. Learn a little about your potential date. Maybe get beyond your first impression. When you have one person in front of you and you're not going to get another one for 24 hours, you might go beyond the picture and read the biography, read actually what they're looking for in a mate, and actually that leads to very different kinds of processes. Tinder based
你可能在看一个易于阅读的属性，甚至不用阅读，很容易看，那就是照片。相比之下，如果你一天只匹配一次，你就可以慢下来。了解一点你的潜在约会对象。也许超越你的第一印象。当你面前有一个人，而且24小时内不会有第二个人时，你可能会超越照片去阅读个人简介，阅读他们在伴侣中寻找的东西，这实际上会带来非常不同的过程。Tinder基于
you're picking on who has a cute headshot, you're thinking very differently if you're on coffee meets bagel. One of the things that I think this this work suggests is sort of a particularly thorny philosophical question, I think, which is that I think we generally have the tendency to assume that we should give people what it is they want. So in other words, that people actually know what it is they want. But of course, that was the case. Then people should be able to choose what it is they want, regardless of the dating site
你是在挑选谁的头像可爱，如果你在Coffee Meets Bagel上，你的想法会截然不同。我认为这项工作表明的事情之一是一个特别棘手的哲学问题，我认为，那就是我们通常倾向于假设我们应该给人们他们想要的东西。换句话说，人们其实知道自己想要什么。但当然，如果是这样的话。那么人们应该能够选择他们想要的东西，不管是什么约会网站
they are using. What we often find when we look at certain dating sites is that people end up with mates, with partners who are very unlike the specifications that they themselves have laid out at the start of the search process. So someone might say, I want someone with characteristics A through C and it turns out that the person they actually like has characteristics D through F. And in some ways it speaks to the idea that even though we think we know ourselves, very often we don't. I think the basic idea is a very fundamental change in the way we think about choice.
他们正在使用。当我们查看某些约会网站时，我们经常发现人们最终得到的伴侣，与他们在搜索过程开始时自己列出的规格截然不同。所以有人可能会说，我想要一个具备A到C特征的人，结果发现他们真正喜欢的人具备D到-F特征。在某种程度上，这说明了这样一个观点，即尽管我们认为我们了解自己，但很多时候我们并不了解。我认为基本观点是对我们思考选择的方式的根本改变。
Economist tend to believe we know what we want and we're simply searching for the right me. I think the reality of dating and the reality of most choice is that we're trying to figure out what it is we want. We're actually trying to assemble a set of preferences to predict who will make us happy. And that assembly process is actually very different and much more likely to be affected by the choice architecture. So we've lived at several ways in which people's choices can be influenced by the way in which choices are presented to them. Now that's great when it comes to helping people, you know, save more for retirement or to increase voter registration. But let's
经济学家倾向于认为我们知道自己想要什么，并且我们只是在寻找合适的匹配。我认为约会的现实和大多数选择的现实是，我们试图弄清楚我们想要什么。我们实际上是在试图拼凑出一套偏好来预测谁会让我们快乐。而这个拼凑过程实际上非常不同，并且更有可能受到选择架构的影响。所以我们已经探讨了几种人们的选择如何受到向他们呈现选择的方式影响的方法。现在，这在帮助人们，你知道，为退休储蓄更多或增加选民登记方面很棒。但让我们
look at a more complex issue. The researcher Scott Halpern once ran a study where he examined how people make decisions about their end of life care. Volunteers were given forms which had pre-checked boxes. Some got a form where the checkbox said they would receive comfort care like hospice. Others got a form which had the option for prolonged medical intervention checked as the default. What did they find Eric? It's actually an amazing study because every participant was actually terminally ill with lung cancer. They were actually making the decision that would actually describe how they would die. And the defaults were amazingly powerful.
来看看一个更复杂的问题。研究人员斯科特·哈尔珀恩曾进行过一项研究，他研究了人们如何对临终关怀做出决定。志愿者们得到了带有预先勾选方框的表格。一些人拿到了一份表格，上面的复选框表明他们将接受像临终关怀这样的舒适护理。另一些人则拿到了一份表格，其默认勾选了延长医疗干预的选项。埃里克，他们发现了什么？这实际上是一项惊人的研究，因为每个参与者实际上都患有晚期肺癌。他们实际上是在做一个将描述他们将如何死去的决定。而默认值具有惊人的力量。
Many more people chose the prolonged care when it was the default than when it was comfort care. What's really important about this study is one other fact, these are very ethical researchers. So they actually went back to each of the participants and said, by the way, you got that particular set of defaults randomly. We essentially flipped a coin to determine how you're going to actually face death. And what happened was only two of the subjects
当延长护理是默认选项时，选择它的人数远多于将其设为舒适护理时的人数。关于这项研究，真正重要的是另一个事实，这些是非常有道德的研究人员。所以他们实际上回访了每个参与者并说，顺便说一句，你随机得到了那一组特定的默认值。我们本质上抛硬币来决定你将如何真正面对死亡。结果是只有两个受试者
actually changed what they chose. So, there's a couple of really complicated philosophical conundrums here. So comfort care was selected 77% of the time when it was the default, but only 43% of the time when life extension, when medical intervention was a default. Now I don't know about you Eric, but it makes me very uncomfortable that these tools are so powerful that they can influence our life and their decisions. And then secondly, even when we tell people
实际上改变了他们的选择。所以，这里有几个非常复杂的哲学难题。因此，当舒适护理是默认选项时，其被选择的比例为77%，而当延长生命、医疗干预是默认选项时，这一比例仅为43%。现在我不知道你怎么样，埃里克，但这让我感到非常不安，因为这些工具如此强大，它们可以影响我们的生活和他们的决定。其次，即使我们告诉人们
that we have used those tools, they will still stick to the choices they made even when they were not aware that the tools were being used on them. So I am similarly uncomfortable, but it's very important to realize that this is what we'll call an assembled preference, that is I'm actually trying to figure out what will be the thing that will make me the most comfortable. And that's a very hard decision,
我们已经使用了这些工具，他们仍然会坚持他们所做的选择，甚至在他们没有意识到这些工具正被用在他们身上时也是如此。所以我同样感到不安，但非常重要的是要意识到这就是我们所说的拼凑偏好，也就是说我实际上在试图弄清楚什么东西会让我最舒适。这是一个非常艰难的决定，
particularly in the case of end of life care. But doesn't it raise questions about what actual individual choice is really about, because it actually suggests that that choice there isn't sort of some innate choice that's inside us that's waiting to be unearthed that we actually have inside us. It actually is all almost made up on the fly. That's right and it's not surprised to me that we don't have a innate preference for one outcome or the other because hopefully we have never made this as before and unfortunately we'll never get to make it again. We can think of both the pros and cons of both sides and what the default does is make us think about
特别是在临终关怀的情况下。但这难道没有对实际的个人选择到底是什么提出疑问吗？因为它实际上表明那里的选择并不是某种存在于我们内心、等待被发掘的内在选择。它实际上几乎是即兴凑出来的。没错，我不感到惊讶的是，我们对某种结果没有内在偏好，因为希望我们以前从未做出过这个决定，而不幸的是我们再也不会有机会做出这个决定了。我们可以思考双方的利弊，而默认值的作用是让我们思考
one versus the other. It's a very troubling result and it's even more troubling when you realize the medical system tends to encourage life extension by the way their forms are constructed. Yeah, so the default for many hospitals and doctors is to actually ask, how can I prolong life? Yeah, I actually asked Scott about that and he says, yes, in fact, explicitly unless you make a choice, unless you opt into comfort care, you'll be given life extension care. And it's not just the good guys who are reading up on choice architecture. The bad guys are doing it too. We all know companies that, you know, sign us up to some subscription at an introductory
一个对另一个。这是一个非常令人不安的结果，当你意识到医疗系统往往通过其表格的构建方式来鼓励延长生命时，这就更加令人不安了。是的，所以许多医院和医生的默认做法实际上是问，我怎样才能延长生命？是的，我实际上问过斯科特关于这一点，他说，是的，事实上，明确地说，除非你做出选择，除非你选择舒适护理，否则你将获得延长生命的护理。而且不光是好人在研究选择架构。坏人也在这样做。我们都知道一些公司，你知道，让我们注册某种订阅，首月
rate of $1 a month, but the fine print says your credit card will be automatically charged $50 a month after three months. And if you try and cancel, it's nearly impossible to find a phone number or if you do find a phone number, you get stuck on hole for two hours as you're trying to cancel. Choice architecture is being used against us all the time. There is a nice name in computer science for that. It's called dark patterns. And they're particularly concerned with the fact where it's easy to opt into something to chew like a subscription. And it's very hard to get out of it. In fact, they have a nice name for it.
价格为1美元，但小字说明会在三个月后自动从你的信用卡扣除50美元。如果你试图取消，几乎找不到电话号码，或者如果你找到了电话号码，在你试图取消时会在电话里被搁置等待两个小时。选择架构一直在被用来对付我们。计算机科学中有一个好听的名字叫这个。它被称为暗黑模式。他们特别关注的是那种容易注册订阅之类的事情。而要退出却非常困难。事实上，他们给它起了一个好听的名字。
It's called a Roach Motel. The customers come in, but they never leave. One of the things that I think is really important to realize is that that's a moral decision that is actually reflected in the choice architecture. I could lie, and that may not be moral, but I could also set the choice architecture up in a way that creates bad outcomes for people. but I can also set the choice architecture up in a way that creates bad outcomes for people. Mm-hmm.
它叫做“罗奇汽车旅馆”（易进难出）。顾客进来，但他们从不离开。我认为真正重要的事情之一是要意识到这是一个道德决定，它实际上反映在选择架构中。我可以撒谎，这可能不道德，但我也可以以一种为人们产生糟糕结果的方式建立选择架构。但我也可以以一种为人们产生糟糕结果的方式建立选择架构。嗯-哼。
So, you know, it makes people really angry when they feel like they are being manipulated. And I think this is true for all of us. And I think many people worry, justifiably, that there is something about choice architecture that is undemocratic. You're superficially giving people the choice to make a decision, but you've set things up
所以，你知道，当人们觉得自己被操纵时，他们会非常愤怒。我想我们所有人都是如此。我认为许多人理所当然地担心，选择架构存在某种不民主的成分。你表面上给人们做出决定的选择，但你把事情设置成
in such a way that they make the decision that you want them to make. Do you worry that choice architecture gives marketers, policymakers, politicians, even experts such as yourself, great power over people? Choice architecture is there whether we're using it to manipulate or not. Someone is deciding lots of things like what is the default, how many options. There's no such thing as no choice architecture. Just because you have your eyes closed doesn't mean it's not there. So what I think is the important thing to do is realize that it exists
以至于他们做出你希望他们做出的决定。你是否担心选择架构赋予了营销人员、政策制定者、政治家，甚至像你这样的专家对人们巨大的权力？无论我们是否用它来操纵，选择架构都在那里。有人在决定很多事情，比如默认值是什么，有多少个选项。没有所谓的没有选择架构这回事。你闭上眼睛并不意味着它不存在。所以我认为重要的是要认识到它的存在
and then to use it to help people make better decisions. Eric Johnson is the author of the Elements of Choice, why the way we decide matters. Eric, thank you for joining us today on Hidden Brain. It's been a huge pleasure, thank you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Brigitte McCarthy, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is Show Fan Lee Lee. Shofans are hidden brain listener and supports the show via our Patreon page.
然后利用它来帮助人们做出更好的决定。埃里克·约翰逊是《选择的元素：为什么我们的决定方式很重要》一书的作者。埃里克，感谢你今天来到《隐秘大脑》。非常荣幸，谢谢。由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、赖恩·卡茨、奥秋·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐秘大脑》的执行编辑。我们今天的无名英雄是秀凡·李（音译）。秀凡是隐秘大脑的听众，并通过我们的Patreon页面支持节目。
As we heard in today's episode, our choices are affected by all sorts of factors, many of which are invisible to us. Choosing to support a podcast takes time, effort and a financial commitment. Thanks for making that decision, Shofan. We're really grateful. If you like Hidden Brain, be sure to check out our new podcast My Unsung Hero. Every episode will boost your faith in humanity in five minutes or less. I'm Shankar Vedanthantham. See you soon. Thank you. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
正如我们在今天的节目中所听到的，我们的选择受到各种因素的影响，其中许多因素对我们来说是隐形的。选择支持播客需要时间、精力和财务承诺。谢谢你做出这个决定，秀凡。我们真的很感激。如果你喜欢《隐秘大脑》，一定要看看我们的新播客《我的无名英雄》。每一集都会在五分钟或更短的时间内增强你对人性的信念。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。谢谢。谢谢。这个节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子来留下评论。